the industrial city of raslafan in Qatar
where gas is cooled to minus 160 degrees
Celsius and turned into liquid
Dr rasler Van Paul to tanka is ready to
deliver supplies to the world
Europe has been switching to liquefied
natural gas or LNG since Russia invaded
Ukraine last year Europe committed to
replacing about 155 billion cubic meters
a year of what Russia was sending to
Europe before The Invasion and they
wanted to replace about 100 billion
cubic meters of that by the end of 2022
by our estimates we've seen they've been
able to do that last year and most of
that replacement has come from sourcing
alternative
supplies of LNG
Qatar is the world's largest supplier of
liquefied gas exporting more than 81
million tons a year that's around 21 of
the global LNG export Market it's
ramping up production in its North Field
that's part of the world's biggest gas
field it's on track to produce 126
million tons per year by 2027. it's good
news for countries like Germany that are
trying to wean themselves off Russian
gas
cattle energy had quartered here in Doha
struck a deal last year with Germany to
supply LNG it agreed to export 2 million
tons annually for at least 15 years from
2026. the deal will supply 2.7 percent
of Germany's annual gas needs it's a
small percentage but sends an important
message
Asia has long been qatar's biggest
export market for LNG but now Qatar
wants to supply more to Europe the
energy dilemmas which European countries
face are extremely serious and there is
no denying that Qatar has certainly been
able to leverage its uh gas wealth to
doha's advantage throughout this
conflict the United States and Algeria
are also supplying Europe with LNG but
as the continent seeks other suppliers
analysts say Qatar is likely to play an
increasingly dominant role
Victoria gaysenby Al Jazeera Doha